[Music]
i think an
artist and an entrepreneur what they
share is something that starts with a
vision
you're artistically creating what that
business is going to be
no matter what the business is we learn
the functions of accounting and
marketing and finance
in art you have a different palette
in my art form starts with trees
my name is william eaton and i attended
the gsb
uh beginning in 1973 and graduated in
1975.
lutherie is art of making and repairing
stringed instruments
the art of lutherie occupies a niche
during the whole building process you're
imagining what will this instrument
sound like
if you add strings you change the cavity
sizes
is it a solid body is it acoustic that's
a wonderful
evolution of what will take place
music was like a soundtrack to my life
when i went to
college i thought it was time to grow up
i was playing guitar primarily as
something that i enjoyed but i never
considered that as a career
my entire family were bankers my dad my
uncles
and i just thought this is this is what
i will do and so
i started researching business schools
and fell in love with stanford
about a year went by and i just said
something's missing
so i'd get back to my room pull out my
guitar and just
listen to the sound of the strings and
really
change my whole sensibility about music
and where it
fit in my life at that time
i was in a course called new enterprise
management
and i remember at that time having a
dream about
making a formalized guitar making school
becoming an entrepreneur was a difficult
decision the professors
that i was consulting with were very
encouraging
they would say things like when will you
have this opportunity again to do this
and that really hit home with me i
really felt somewhere
deep in myself that this is something i
wanted to do the plan was pretty
ambitious
when i arrived in phoenix i had no
resources and john roberts who was the
proprietor
and so was bob van who was his partner
at the time john and bob didn't either
many of the hardwoods used
in instrument making come from tropical
zones
rain forest areas the wood we started
out with that john
harvested in nicaragua he worked for a
lumber company
so all this wood that we started the
school was basically
recycled wood that had been left behind
those trees are milled into usable
pieces that will
become a musical instrument
[Music]
one of the most valuable lessons that i
learned at gsb
was learning to focus focusing on what's
really important
people ask me about achievements in
music and recording and composing it's
it's really a byline to what i started
with with creating the guitar making
school
in entrepreneurial life this is one of
the really wonderful things that comes
later
things that you don't expect i never
imagined a career
as a performer but making one-of-a-kind
stringed instruments
what comes from that is for me another
career
it forever changed my life and i'm still
doing it and
enjoy it thoroughly
[Music]
you